hello and welcome to this video I like
so forgetting the name of that crime
doesn't have one but he's one of those
icy see all these is only a for ages and
so yeah let's go to mt for and prevent
bishop be fun at the Petrosian system
get this line and playing something
solid him
yeah I cannot expect a huge advantage in
white but it is some and easy to play
position so maybe just take him before
trying to play against this is power so
we should be 20 bishop d2 may be here so
that a 4 can be supported you can go see
5 no isn't this good I don't know c 5
i'll take and d5 hangs so I'm winning
this pawn here right yep i winning this
point it's not so bad so going here 94
and Knight to c6 that is the dream
scenario here can also just go back to
you 10 a five year
Bishop before it's more interesting than
bishop you won the thing i have to take
care with us the step-back rank yeah
here bishop be one this room d 1 I
should've played for sure before one
move earlier that would have been better
really would have been better so sure
before and there isn't route do you want
actually because at the end I have /
should be you on so I can go here I can
definitely assure you that i'm going to
play h3 soon that seems dangerous here I
don't threaten to take on c5 because of
this route d1 business okay so h3r takes
first I'm going to take first and then
let's go age 3 m
now he also has slide back rank issues
every Quincy forms Quincy for taking
this night could be m at least I was
quick about all this
this guy's ICC account must be like 20
years old I really remember him from
back in the day I didn't really
calculate here which I should have done
going to f5 maybe yeah bit awkward this
awkward or can I just snatch stuff I
mean I don't really see a big thread at
the moment but and it feels scary
somehow it's got active pieces
and covering F to Bishop d for this
queen d 8 I think I'm threatening a
threatening the Queen as well it's not
easy now where is he going there's also
Queen something Quincy for Quincy to
Quincy to is somewhat awkward as a root
move will give away the night yeah maybe
I'm fine with this counter counter blow
94 twin f4 might also be good idea
yeah it's not quite clear way where he
goes in the first place then so Quincy
to or what let's do that well oh my god
takes Queen shakes shoot you see
threatening something though I mean I
can go right here didn't see rogue III
at all but it's rock I mean wherever you
move that Hanks the night so and I'm
attacking the aid maybe I'm still okay
now is really really trying to kill me
here right wow it looks very dangerous
context king of one rope t5 stuff like
that okay here's going to be one rookie
one okay one takes on f2 Wow takes on
have two can have one check check
time morning
I don't see him okay one looks simsim
stain seems deadly Riley yeah I don't
see I don't see a giant amazing check
here I know chicks taking queena for
cannot believe that I'm not shy DGM
check hmm that move I didn't see even
Wow check check white forfeits on time
wow wow that was great what he did I
mean he was totally busted completely
busted I'm pretty sure but that was
great stuff or maybe it's not so clear
anyway I couldn't believe it and here
Queen g5 and the engine to give zero
give zero that's really hard to believe
but maybe it is the canes rookie three
arm that that's great yeah
okay when I saw this but check this sis
didn't feel enough to me this saw that
actually this is the end of line but I
wanted to I didn't check I didn't think
that this is enough I thought I could
would win with 96 but jeez Freitas win
for black amazing stuff I really i
didn't i have no i really have no move
if i take it Queen chicks here ok 92 is
given by the computer i was thinking
this move and yeah it's also willing now
I'm busted I'm just lost him just lost
Wow
that's amazing i have to take the draw
here with fts have to take the drawn and
I didn't see g3 obviously this is the
the issue i was thinking okay like
everything hangs but he can go with g3
and this is introducing rookie 1g takes
f to grade check and the auto or what
was also great he found the quickest
possible winner i guess check at least
it looked like it chat with his check I
was thinking Queen f4 mostly and yeah it
probably will win his way I would check
yeah I thought as I can kind of continue
but I guess this one it's lost in any
way great yeah that was great what did
he tell his great stuff okay he's crude
of this opening but got some kind of
compensation this is a mistake yeah I
should go Bishop before him this is
stronger that the day five move didn't
help me if he does this now I can can
actually take check check
how come on I have rookie 10 until I die
can take the Queen that was a stronger
now well it's not objectively enough for
black boots we saw that it got Ricky
looks is six is good the computer also
gives this line with the draw funny Anna
with some kind of Perpetual at the end
rugby to between age five and ruby three
check check check check and it's some
perpetual at the end that's good it's
very believable crazy position yeah I
was a was a great game by if I my
opponent thanks for watching